et là je vois mavericks la plus grosse
vague du monde se refermait au moins
j'ai bien cru bon dernier ride était
arrivé sans tonne de pression g est
direct qui tombe dessus
y'a pas un bateau qui peut résister
puis on n'en parle jamais parce que
personne n'est jamais rentré du vendée
une vague a décidé d'emmener au fond
rien ni personne que la raison
c'est pia et
écorchée par le corps ait complètement
muet
appeler au secours mais dans la merde
personne ne vous entend crier
et comment t'as fait pourtant sorti je
ne peux pas trop jamais en parler de ça
disons que j'ai quelques amis chez les
dauphins
waouh t'es vraiment un dieu de la mer
oui maudit lui ce n'est pas sortir body
body patrick swayze en prime break
patrick swayze on freine brightpoint
break fut pas une break
un drap a beau dire viendra pas
et le linge est gentil q1
profitez questions
faux la classe atteints de poisson pané
tapas juillet tu as déjà pisser dessus
et nettoie le voleur
m
un pack
moi pour vous
pas peureux la vague et du surf
[Musique]
ça brise
pourquoi tu ignores par là n'ont pas
trop ferme en garde et moins
noisy j'ai même regardé
[Musique]
il va rien se passer 1
on vise 3 le 19 octobre au cinéma
moi je me classe mme rice c'est ton
meilleur ami secours rejoint mois au
plus vite prendre le premier avion
le premier avion s'il te plaît premier
avion pour vous
[Musique]
ah ben je sais pas trop vite
3 ouais parce que le 2e les casser